okay four people joining this livestream
this is one of our series of meetings
working on database integration for the
upcoming version of Wolfram language and
we had a bunch of controversial issues
which we were addressing in that last
meeting so this is a summary of what was
going on we have entities we have entity
classes are they always equivalent
through a list of entities the proxy or
a discreet list of entities
algebraically yes I mean in terms of the
what and Lee model was yes so enter the
value of an entity class gives what the
list of results from the entity class so
if you if you are using to the value on
an entity and one property you get a
scalar if you use it on an empty class
and on an empty property class you get a
rank two tensor so that's formula okay
an entity value does not have an
aggregator built into it I mean it does
have a third argument but it's kind of
an abuse organization so you imagine
that the aggregation of an entity value
well through other people in this
meeting agree with that statement yes
all right
okay and it will list my met what does
this claim so entity list here
okay so for example if I say and that
entity list if I say entity list of g8
here g8 is an entity class right okay
now I say entity list your entity list
of that same thing it will not return
the same thing because of what explained
below what the heck is that so then I
basically the problem is that you need
to somewhat simplify the we what goes in
the first argument of the entity let's
scroll down there's a okay by the way
that formatting is obviously very
troubled for some reason it's escaped
the entity class formatting there I
don't know why what I'm saying okay okay
there is actually another type of object
another type of object is entity types
yeah but entity types work like entity
classes they're the same thing but
they're not I mean they have that if you
ask for entity type I mean no it's
something like country it's not as such
an entity class is it it is it's like an
country is actually a short form of
entity class country all so it's dlz
it's a trivial entity class where you
don't feel anything okay well so entity
list is a slightly bizarre and slightly
heuristic thing yes so so these are the
things that we can simplify but it's
it's strictly recursive so you can't
simplify like you can only peel the
outer layers you cannot peel the inner
ones and so most of these don't commute
with okay but so so so what so entity
list we're agreeing is a somewhat
heuristic thing and it's not part of the
mainstream of what's going on
what is this about
yeah it's about the operational entities
so the solution is like the currently
implemented version is that we strip
what we can and we fail otherwise no
that's fine I mean I'm saying entity
list is a heuristic thing that does what
it can first and tries to solve in the
way that it resolves today as a useful
utility for resolving classes of
entities where it is possible to resolve
it down to raw entities yeah but this
this thing I mean I guess the question
is what what does it mean for I mean do
non-raw entities exist or not who won't
come or should they be considered entity
classes no they can't be considered
entity classes because they
algebraically may behave like hamsters
okay so I thought we agreed last time
that we could have non raw entities but
it entered in list if it cannot resolve
to R or entities it resolves to the best
next best thing okay
and then the question is do we also want
something which is like entities may be
called full entity list that doesn't try
to result in it's not heuristic why what
would it do that was useful it's it's
very useful actually to remember the
query you came from because but why do
you need a resolver at all why aren't
you using entity value to be the
resolver you know sometimes you just
want to look at what empties come out
and maybe take one or two after looking
at them so you're doing the case you
aggregate over continents then you look
at the result and you realize that all
you're interested in is the aggregated
Europe okay so you wanna that's
something that's something you might
want to use that's non non base so and
the other case is when you are your
filtered something and you want to make
sure that the filter is still valid when
you extract the values out of that
single entity
um so so you want identity Italy but
when Italy gets kicked out of g8 stops
existing okay I didn't understand okay
so hold on hold on let's review what we
are trying to okay so with respect to
the other functions that we're dealing
with
where is the list of all of them because
I don't think online of everything now
wicked blobs from last time
what were those notes cooled please 16
is doubly notes 16 so at the bottom you
will starting to write like descriptive
names for these okay
is this what I wrote last time yes okay
all right and is this every function
that we're trying to deal with or not
yes okay all right okay so now what are
you saying here so you're saying
I mean we don't need the new functions
for that the big like for example Jade
because you want to take the Antilles of
g8 and there is one mode where you
trying to resolve that down to these
entities and you get out thing yes yes
but but imagine you are doing something
like you're doing some kind of two-step
operation where you're getting all the
people who haven't paid you back yet and
then one of them pays you and you have
this so on I don't understand what what
is you've already got this thing which
is your result of your queries it's an
entity class of some kind what are you
trying to resolve in that entity class
that isn't the heuristic resolution of
entity list
to understand my question why aren't you
just leaving it as the entity class
but because I think that people are used
to this workflow I mean single objects
are useful in many cases also sense if
you don't have single energies then the
whole energy frameworks framework you
know in some sense goes out of the
windows too
why don't we eventually list a second
argument
or I mean we've got to explain to people
I mean so this has to work we have to be
able to resolve and enter the class into
individual entities I don't quite
understand what when that won't work
could you explain it okay so that will
work in all cases now the question is
that I think that there are some
workflows where you somewhat won't
remember what what the original query
was so it's like I want that's a
different thing so I want something
where I don't have to remember a
heuristic but where were these very
simple identity holds between what
entity list is and what the first
argument to entity is so what is that
identity what is the identity the one
you have on your screen now in one okay
so when does that I'm sorry when does
that hold that only holds for base
entities know that the problem is that's
right right now that this thing will
hold only for things that we aren't able
to simplify what I'm saying is no I
don't understand that canonical name is
not something you can get not the second
that's not what I'm looking at I'm
looking at this piece of code and this
piece of code will fail when the thing
is not a base entity what will it be
can be a list it can be yeah I don't
understand I don't understand why why
isn't this what is the thing you're
trying to do here you're trying to get
something where these entities contain
instead of the base type as their first
argument they contain something which
has the history of where that thing came
from is that what you're saying yeah so
in the case in this particular case what
you want is this yeah rather than a
thing where it has resolved down to
knowing that that thing so how would you
resolve this down to the raw Canada
what would be the function that resolves
it down to that that's that's not a
question I don't know what what I need
to know and it's not possible in for
generality it's only possible for some
hands okay so let's review then what it
is that okay so let's review we've got
several things okay so this is now I
guess I have to start number seventeen
now
so we have we have the notion of entity
list okay and we have then an entity
okay so entity with composite type
okay by the way it's sort of unfortunate
that the type system has um is yet
another version of some of the stuff we
have things like typed and so on
am i making sense
and I assume that there's no sense in
trying to merge that concept here in a
sense this is much lazier well it's not
much lazier than I mean so
that has a thing called type specifier
okay which is a way of I mean I I don't
know whether that's related okay that's
a piece of unification I think we're not
thinking about right now I think and
figure out okay there is for sure some
kind of contact when you are inspecting
the types that are coming up from the
database columns absolutely absolutely
and those you should use this type
specification I hope you are doing that
right now
are you know not well you need to you
need to merge the names of the types
right for sure absolutely know the yeah
that's I mean the names of the types
from binary read or something else mmm
some of them could but the problem is
that really it is also very useful at
inspection time to know what is what is
the name of the type in the dialect so
they have some funky stuff like March
are twenty actually still on I
personally wouldn't use the same name
for the types were using for databases
because they are very different and that
would be only confusing I think well why
are they so different I mean eventually
a compiled function might run on the
database yeah no because the types are
various some of them are very specific
to a given back-end other than those
which are not they are specific to the
SQL world much more than say the types
you are used to for programming
languages I mean in a sense to them
there is a problem that there's a like
so for example they have things like
binary encoded dates with or without
timezone there is not really astute
correspondence types in the language so
I mean maybe there is a way to specify
them with the similar but but then carlo
i mean that that is one part of the
existing Danielle
there is the type system that what kind
of type is you told from the database
that is a data of an integrator Oriel or
things like that so we need in any way
stream to investigate if that is related
in terms of eye level in types that you
know you are defined and you're getting
up from your essence
ultimately you get a string you don't
get much all right okay sure actually
[Music]
okay hold on
okay that's separate discussion okay so
what you've got here is this notion of
resolve entity potentially which takes
an entity whose that contains an entity
class and attempts to resolve the entity
to a base entity and then you either
have something like unresolved entity
list or entity list
blah blah blah comma and then something
like unresolved or some such other thing
bunch of heuristics we could we could I
mean in other words we can say this
could be the you know F could be the
resolution function so we could say
entity list blah
como res with a resolution function okay
and and so for example the default would
be you know entity list of of blah blah
blah comma resolved entity maybe but
then you could also have um entity lists
common none which would be your your uh
identity basically what's a identity
yeah yes yes so let's let's try this out
for a minute okay but let's go back and
look at what some of these functions
actually are okay so that that will be a
way to deal with this issue so I don't
completely understand what resolve
entity does
okay so it attempts to find out whether
there is in fact attempts to resolve a
base entity to a base entity at the
current time right
that makes sense no no no no resolve
entity is not actually so if if you feed
the resolved entity an entity this is
completely algebraic and happens on the
Wolfram language side I don't care I
want to know there's no no this is a non
lazy function but also lazy function
correct yeah it's not not a lazy
function but there is no notion of of
time okay okay there is a notion of time
because you were just making that whole
production about how what if you have a
customer who pays you later but that
happens
I mean resolve entity can always resolve
and always will resolve to the same
thing the problem is when you do entity
value on a resolved or unresolved ante
you get a different result but the
resolver does not depend on time these
what this is doing is only removing the
filters the sorting and some operation
that can be removed and but but is not
actually executing anything so it's it's
really just a symbolic operation so but
how can it remove sorting without
actually doing the sorting because you
have a single entity and that pot for a
single entity doesn't care resolve to
base entity um okay so it removes
removes the computational stuff in the
entity class that doesn't matter to a
single entity yeah but it can make a
difference because if you were coming
from I understand I even sorting might
make different I understand I understand
can we now look back at these functions
okay so I think we have a possible
solution here for what you've been
talking about that yes yeah I I like it
do you like it Tony Tony
not sure yet
you
okay well if you've got a different
suggestion please make it otherwise
we're going to move on
okay so this is probably not this is we
don't really need unresolved entity list
at this point right unless we turns out
that's such a common thing that we will
end up wanting it makes sense
yes am I making sense yeah yeah I mean I
I was favoring fluency list but I don't
really like that I think it suggests
that there are more entities in it
okay all right let's go back over to the
side okay okay
extended entity class
so let's remind remind ourselves of the
syntax for that so that is an extended
entity class and then it takes a class
here and then does what and then it says
and then it takes a little or at least
some rules you know new arrow func is
that correct
we're func is an entity function yes
okay all right so that's okay all right
aggregated entity class
okay so now remind me what that looks
like if you want to look at the
implementation is on the other notebook
but basically agreed identity class
takes a class as the first argument
mm-hmm then it's it has a syntax that
looks like the end extended the
extension so it's gonna be like a new
goes to wench function oh gosh this
horrible mess yeah we need to unravel us
okay we really need to unravel us so the
question is what is the fastest path to
get the total of something in an entity
class okay so that is one way to do that
without naming a new entity in this time
I'm said without naming a new property
right so perhaps we need here but I
added a short term there if you look in
the notebook like right just CC goes to
total aggregate symbols to total the
second if that mean it means do the
total of C and call it C does that make
sense
I mean so okay so let's look at that
case okay so you say C arrow AG fun
right
so home what this will do is that
modifies represents an entity class
where the C property of the entity class
I don't understand this at all
is obtained from the individual entity
elements by applying AG fun yes
right thing by a play AG fun to actually
do class of C forgive me - cause I don't
assign cost what is class trust though
you have eaten Bob oh okay yeah - but
it's not just cause of C is it yeah it
is is you're doing the total of pluses
to classes see we return a list of
values okay so let's try an example of
this okay okay so what you're saying in
let's do the example for our ordinary
entities right so let's go through this
get entity framework you can probably
try it out
no no I don't want to do that I don't
want to do the actual function I want to
see what this does right with an entity
class let's say g8 as our evidently
class okay and now let's try GDP of that
okay so that returns a list is that
obvious why that returns a list yes it
is because entity classes are lists like
anti properties are scalar so okay so
now one thing I can do here is to just
say total of that which is happy right
so now the issue is what do you want to
do here the issue is how you put back
into the data set put back into the
entity class a new property no no the
point is that you get a completely new
entity class that represents all of the
countries of Jade in one entity so I
think it's better if I don't know but
that's not that that's wrong that's
wrong because this is not no no no no no
are you telling me that this is
generating a singleton entity class yes
okay
I think it's not really treated as an
entity it's not treated as an entity
okay so so here's what we want to say
here right take the whole entity class
okay
this essentially creates a singleton
entity class
in which
there are aggregated
um properties derived from an entity
class right Sienna I just think that by
looking at the two argument version
we're looking at that at the degenerate
case so it is it the case that it
creates a single tenant because it does
always create a single of an entity
class no I'll give you the answer class
returns a single 20 class where he has
two arguments there's three arguments it
groups on the third argument and so if
the grouping function returns four
distinct things you get not singleton
but we haven't it comes with four
entities okay all right okay okay okay
so it creates an entity class
you
of
by aggregating
and today's in an existing entity class
and
um
I wait wait wait wait wait wait wait and
giving them aggregated properties
correct absolutely I would use grouping
in the first no no no the whole point is
that it's aggregation that's why it's
called aggregated entity class yeah but
you first group by the third argument
and then aggregate with the functions
otherwise I understand that I understand
it but I think it's easier to understand
what's going on okay so let's walk
through what can happen here okay so
this is saying so what you're basically
doing so let's walk through a simple
case okay um so what we're saying is
let's let's imagine I'm just gonna do
population arrow and aggregation
function is total let's say GDP and the
aggregation function is actually more
complicated because it's an entity well
as you know GDP let's say GDP per capita
okay makes sense
so they're the aggregation function has
to be an entity function that takes the
tell me what this should be okay so that
would be so you want the mean what do
you want at all the mean okay so that
would be I guess there is a meaningful
total that's the whole point I mean that
the whole point is yeah GDP has a Tokyo
KKK so that thing what would it be it
would be you sum all the GDP s and you
sum all the popu so it would be total of
GDP divided by total right of P
population
so in fact even though that was so there
is no way to derive it GDP per capita
the aggregate of GDP per capita from the
aggregate of the individual GDP per
capita x' it has been agreed arrived
like this
right
yes which is fine okay so let me try to
understand what this is so this will now
be an aggregated entity class in which
the grandfathered properties right are
um in which only those three properties
are available is that correct yes okay
so now are there any properties that you
wish to be grandfathered in general I
think it's I mean if you want that you
have to set in your entity store some
kind of default aggregator I okay Loney
can you comment on default aggregators
we could introduce them but it might
depend on the context what you prefer a
Seaforth aggregator okay fine fine
for instance there might be extensive
properties but in some context you might
do a different application okay all
right okay
all right so I understand what this is
doing this seems like a perfectly
reasonable function here okay
and I think even its name is reasonable
aggrieved okay now I wanted to consider
the the case of the the three argument
case
okay
so this is one this will always produce
a singleton right yeah okay so now let's
look at the case where we want to divide
that by continent as well
okay so we want to produce so this is a
case which I'm now not completely
understanding so we're wanting instead
of aggregating completely we want to
divide by continent so how do we do that
just we say being continent there okay
so that third argh is like an arc to
group by is that right yes so it's like
the second arc of group by okay so let's
take an example of that okay so let's
say group by and then let's say our
friendly entity list of g8 makes sense
and then what I want to say is group by
continent there that what I would say I
don't know if no you can't do it that
way you need entity property
you
it's that right well isn't it oh oh
because I need to say country
right
okay cool asaurus okay right okay so I
think I understand now
then okay so let's take a look
what is the name all right fine I get
this that makes sense to me okay
is it that okay now the question is if I
did an entity list on the aggregate what
would those individual so what to the
individual entry what do the individual
group two entries look like an answer
list question mark so these this is a
case where we cannot simplify I realize
that but what do they look like what do
they go in this case they would look
like entity of aggregated entity class
blah blah blah or that stuff come okay
so they say entity of aggregated entity
class well the whole thing the class not
until list
yeah entity class and in which case it's
the whole big giant spec big spec right
then comma in this case you can just put
North Mary
content on the robbery of the continent
okay okay so in that case it's the UM
it's the output from the grouping
function
right or all functions if you have a
list okay okay right so in this case and
the list is resolving the ruling at the
time you run it I mean yeah but it's not
resolving the first audience always we
know Linda yes right right right so what
it does okay this makes sense to me I'm
finally understanding this this makes
good sense
Alleluia okay but I think it really I
mean I don't whether you have this
syntax before but this syntax kind of
this you know this makes it make sense
you're you're you're you're specifying
it's a new and the syntax was switched
and we had a by version and a nun by
version okay fine okay so then let's
talk about what so it's really useful
here that when you do properties you get
out all the properties that are
accessible
we already doing this
yeah aunty properties works okay so I've
got a question in the single dn't case
what does this thing look like when
there's no output from the group in
function I would say an empty list what
about all all is problematic for for
okay all right foot for the case for the
singleton case with no grouping function
the
quotes entity list output should be okay
so it's this thing here
and then you're saying you're just
saying analyst there or it could be one
but not all in one even the number one
yeah could be that but oh my weight is
good no matter Kelly issue if you're
reading in by any and you'd like entity
off and then the blast country would the
least work that I don't understand the
question okay so I've got a crazy idea
let's ask what the default grouper is
okay what is the default grouping
what does group by if group by were to
leave everything in one group what would
be the default function that you use to
do the grouping result I don't know it's
it's the only thing is that he has from
here a constant function that is
arbitrary constant function yes also for
aggregated entity class the default
corresponds to using an empty list in
the third argument which corresponds to
using an empty list of properties
sorry wait a minute Tony is that is that
an attack on the sort of support of this
noise for the empty list okay okay fine
by the way
if you can actually do group by with an
empty second argument obviously and it
will just work right I mean cuz if I did
that so to demonstrate this that would
give a single turn right
I mean somewhat bizarrely we'll give a
singleton there yeah somewhat miserly is
it because yeah the problem with group
by the reason why I'm cool but why
doesn't group by why does this not
return an association because group by
is hierarchical so if this thing if you
in group by you put like three functions
in the list then you get nest and
associations okay fine so this is the
natural thing is not but we intend to in
this case in aggregated entity cost we
can simply have a list of functions and
then what does it dude is it also it
uses them as so if you put the list of
functions II cannot obviously cannot
yeah it just generates it just users
makes makes names for the output that
contain values of each function in a
yes so if you've got three functions
it's like it's taking the outer product
of those things
yes yes exactly okay I understand
okay to an existing entity cost to add
some new to an existing entity class and
this creates a new entity class by
you're getting entries an existing class
you
okay all right
and by the way student ID that this is
actually a much better grounding for for
implicit entities then so if you think
about like the food entities for example
you can think of them as grouped by say
food type aggregated by fruit type yes
so it would be I think a better
algebraic structure on which to build
increased entities well I don't know I
can't comment on that so Tony question
it's like it's like implicit entities
are shorthand for this really well that
I can believe all right gives a new
entity class with a filtered set of
entities okay
so that is something where you say so
let me see if I understand this so this
would be filtered entity class
and then it's a class and then it's
basically a criterion is that correct
yeah it's like works like select so it's
like a more powerful version of okay so
let me just understand what this would
be like so this is like this thing our
friendly g8 and then it might say
greater than
you
um hash population you cannot rather
than their well cheese grater
you
okay perfectly reasonable our message
magnificent
okay so you're saying that a filtered
entity class
is just this okay I'm good with this any
other any other features of filtered
entity class to discuss I mean this is
one of the cases where it would make a
difference to resolve or not resolved
it's not resolving that's the whole
point so so no no when you do instantly
say mean yes well entity less should try
to resolve against the whole point
right exactly so
you
I mean Encinitas should try and resolve
as far as it can default entered a list
should try to resolve
okay merged entity class
you
okay I don't understand this
what is this one so this one very simple
case you take the countries and you you
want each country to have all the
properties of the capital as well okay
so this is so this creates an extended
entity class
in which yes yes yes it's the same as an
extended ended class I could write
merged entity class no why not because
because for example like the example
with cities is simple because there is
only one capital per country but you
could have you have you can have cases
where you have mentioned function that
is an arbitrary function and the most
general case ok let's take a look at
this hold on
but before I before before you jump me
into that incredibly complicated case ok
so there's a simple case ok
creates an entity class
you
well an extended entity class it really
is the same type
of idea in which
um properties
computed from another entity class have
been included differences - okay the
biggest one is that in the new entity
the old canonical name for the first one
which you extend is no longer enough to
uniquely identify the new entity that
you get and the reason is that you can
have basically are the same original
entity plus more than one extended one
that is joined okay okay okay so let's
let's think about this again so you've
got you know we'll consider the case
where there's doesn't South Africa have
multiple capitals I think it does that
let's assume it does for the sake of our
discussion right Netherlands really I
think that they have like a royal seat
and Myanmar had a winter and summer okay
all right good always good to know these
obscure cases okay and doesn't Western
Sahara not have its capital at all I
forgotten but anyway
okay so so what this is doing is it is
so it is creating from multiple entity
classes or is it always to soy stool
maybe one day we'll turn to entity
classes a new entity class
you
labeled by entities from both these
entity classes
is that correct mm it's labeled by the
canonical names indexed rather than
label by both canonical names really so
I was it join or Union D entities and
post classes it joins but at the
property level not at the entity level
so it's reading the most general merged
entity class where where the condition
is a constant rule is the cross product
okay all right so I understand so then
okay so what it has is a merging
criterion so it has a merged entity
class and has class 1 class 2 right
then it presumably has so it can have
their it can have either a property if
it's present in only recommend we put
those in a list in case we one day deal
with triples on things
we're going to do that but join across
thousand and if we generalize this we
journalize also drivers
it is also not clear to me whether he
can generalize us unambiguously without
going back to kind of making binary
operation and then building the general
one out of the binary one which is what
will happen if you just do more than two
classes and I'm not sure that you can
have a ternary operation I turned her
against the function compilable to twice
QL well that's kind of what I said a
different way
I'm sorry sorry sorry could you could
you repeat it
mmm I got distracted by something here
what I was saying is that when you if we
ever want to generalize the join or
merge operation to more than two classes
I'm not sure you can do that
consistently other than just saying that
you you know you you first do two and
then you add more and more and more so
all right okay all right so let's let's
imagine it's just this then yeah okay
okay so now what's the next argument
you
maybe I should remember truly
complicated so hopefully it doesn't as
complicated as that could be a little
more complicated if you want and if we
want to support everything that SQL does
it can be more complicated than this
okay keep going
just tell me what no the third argument
easy they're a property or a rule or a
list of rules or a list of properties or
an entity function so the most general
case is obviously the entity function
okay well let's take the entity function
first okay so there's a func there and
that function is in binary function has
two arguments go okay so funk has takes
an element from class one
class one entity and a class two entity
right yeah
and it returns what boolean
if it's true it keeps it if it's false
it throws it away
so that's the equivalent of not grouped
by but what's the what's the thing that
wills the outer it will be louder and
then select outer with this function as
a criteria no wait wait a second wait a
second wedding don't we have a function
that can that determines for that does
pairwise comparisons like sort by
default those pairwise comparisons and
sort by doesn't
so we don't have this would be the
function group if we had it correct
horrible name but yes it does that make
sense
Islanders yeah because group by like
sought by computes the by function first
right and then those comparisons of that
sort on the other hand takes a
comparator right and that comparator in
the case of sorters is - I don't
understand the correspondence with group
by okay because because what you're
doing is you're saying this is what you
should merge right if this is slightly
different still on you first make a
cross product of these two things and
then you just say keeping that cross
product only those for which this
function gives true I realize that I
understand that and it's not the
grouping for the grouping you can't make
it I think you can't make it work
because your comparison has to be
transitive for that and there is a
priori you don't know that maybe okay
all right all right all right all right
so then then you're saying this defines
what to keep in the outer product
of entities from class 1 color class 2
okay so let's look at the simplest case
ok simplest case is complete outer
product yeah ok
in that case what we're talking about is
merged entity class class 1 class 2 and
what is the function here that's simply
true ampersand right
correct except that will be in this case
if you are using entity synthesis will
be ended function but yes why does it
need to be entity function because it
has slightly different semantics from
functions like I I think you were
against having functions be taken apart
and and I mean we need we need to case
look an entity function does what it
does and applies to entities but in this
case it doesn't need to apply to
entities does it it does all right
let's write it out as the entity
function so you're saying entity
function of X Y comma true is that
correct yes
okay okay so now let's take now we want
so maybe we'll have a show you want the
ridi ridi outer product you probably
probably need to add outer as the third
are at the fourth argument I'm not sure
what will happen when you have missing
probably nothing here no maybe you don't
they're mine
okay so next case is what is selection
based on a property
but now wait a minute this merged thin
what when you do this it will have so in
this case
um every merged entity will have the
properties from both the class one and
class two is that correct yeah and if
class one and class two happen to be the
same you need the rule to alias one of
them well actually not necessarily when
then even if they happen to be in two
halves
they can't have things that are the same
because because it's an entity property
of entity type comma whatever yeah yeah
but but if you're merging person with
person okay so hold on okay so okay so
then the question is what happens if
class one and class two are of the same
type okay
then
okay then the new properties or what now
if class one and class two are the same
completely the same and you don't alius
them than these fields is you're doing
meaningless operation okay what you're
saying is in order to do this we have to
be able to get the properties from both
class one and class two and we have to
be able to distinguish for any given
property which one came from class one
and which came from class - yes yeah and
what you would write is something like I
don't know merged entity class and then
you have person and the second person
you say I don't know father goes first
on and then you go on to join number on
them okay hold on then we need aliases
for the either of the classes all the
properties as it turns outs to them
aliases for classes are enough okay well
I'm sure they're enough you of course
they're enough but it might not be the
most convenient thing so what you're
saying is okay so so one version of that
might be merged entity class of alias
one hello
class one alias - arrow class - you
actually it's enough to only Alice one
typically okay well fun but you could
alias both of them yeah you could okay
so then what that will do is to name the
properties with that alias in them as
well correct yes and in general if you
do this nesting more than once then
those aliases will also be multi
fragment so to speak well they'll say a
ro BL oh yeah property okay okay fine so
I understand that okay so selection
based on a property um so in that case
then we've got something like merged
entity class
um so now what would this look like this
would say I don't quite understand this
this will say what why is there X&Y that
that's X's from classroom on that's that
right and why is that correct okay so
now walk me through selection based on a
property so
what is this doing this is adding
so let's consider the case of adding the
population of a capital city
if you just want to add the population
you don't need all of this there's me
you can do it with extended this adds
all of them okay but yeah if you wanna
if you mash together the city with a
country you would have like population
okay okay okay that will be okay so
merging properties of a capital city
with into properties of a country so
then what does that look like that says
country is class one country class you
can just use a stream country there sit
across okay that's well that's okay
let's do this case then so country
thirty cloths at a okay now what
now there is one I mean at this point
you don't need to use entity function
but that would be I guess what would it
be if you did use that to the function
okay
X X of capital city in the body yeah
equal equal and then I think this is
just Y yeah this is just Y explain so X
I see the capital city yeah okay fine
that's the criterion
so then what does this look like what do
the new
so if I do entity list on this alright
so the question is then you hear you're
doing an inner join so you will have the
same number of entities as country but
in fujian ID we cannot say that that's
enough
so each entity will be indexed like
Italy Rome France Paris and so on okay
so this generates generates
entities indexed both by the name of a
country the canonical name yeah
and the canonical name of a city
right and there might just be one of
those but if a city if they're if
Capitol City
I mean this isn't right because if
capital city is a list this is the wrong
thing
right what it really should say the
correct version would be
no no no no no no no with capital C
disease oh I see what you're saying okay
right it's member Q we support that
action
unfortunately in SQL it can never be
list can be an entity class but we
support member to an ant a class in it
okay okay
all right we're getting there here let's
just look
sorry you can also have short hands
where I mean where you can when if
you're just doing equality then then
it's pretty you can express it as a rule
instead of as an entity function okay so
equivalently in this case that would be
what yeah
in that case you can probe will be
capital city goes to automatic or
capital city goes 20
I don't understand double eagles as one
entity is a special property which is
basically identity
but I think we can also support
automatic because it means the whole
thing but yeah and in there is another
case which is even simpler that if you
have only one relation between the two
classes you don't need a third argument
and that is called the natural join SQL
putting it by one relation so remember
in the entity store I was showing you in
the in the in the output form there were
those things with the little arrows
those are really those relations are
properties that return entities right we
are out of time here can we can we we
can continue this but let's just look
very very very quickly at this at this
extract identity clause so this one we
said that maybe we could merge it into
sorted because kind of doesn't make
sense you if you don't sort first oh
this is the thing okay so this is the
one that says okay so look I think what
we should call this is sample sampled
entity class or something
really what this is it's more like a
you know okay so one question that we
have here is how do we deal with random
entity
because random entity is another that's
another resolver I think random entity
like entity like entity value random
entity should be like entity value and
resolve it is currently okay so fine so
it's another thing which is a resolver
like entity list leggins released yeah
the main problem is that it might be
very complicated to implement efficient
random entity then that's life I mean
then it doesn't work in some cases but
in other cases it works okay so
[Music]
so here we might just call this um I'm
thinking about
sampled entity class
you
which means you know do some sampling in
some reasonable way yeah I mean right
now the things we can do is basically
just have limited the number of things
that come out and let's talk some apps
this is for the future yeah
you can't you can't say give me the ends
okay all right so then this will be
sorted entity class
but is it in fact a sorted by it is in
fact assorted by okay so then there's a
class and then there's for example
population and then we can say you know
five here or we can also say minus five
right
mmm has to work yeah yeah okay but
because that minus five means but then
which order do the minus 5s come out in
swingers because sort sorts from
smallest population to largest to get
what I'm saying
and we are ascending and descending I we
don't have that we don't have that we
have reversed sort we have in in in sort
of NT class we went to an ILD meeting
asked them to added to sort by side use
a string for now
I hate it so it's from smallest to
largest
the problem is that if you have multiple
sorting functions each of them can be
you know can be ascending or descending
independently so you can just do reverse
or I understand but what what do we do
in the case of what does multiple sorted
do what okay this is another discussion
sort by should be able to deal with this
as well right absolutely and we we try
to propose it almost one year ago now
so the concept is
okay that's a
discussion with a separate set of people
okay that would be some kind of sort by
list you know f1 f2 or something very
bizarre which says you know ascending or
something
well basically we could have F 1 goes to
P 1 F 2 goes to P 2 and so on and these
ascending and descending strings are
just shortcuts or name of where that
will be this wouldn't it yes or more
like
but if you put something sleazy and
people would think they could put
anything there which isn't true why
shouldn't they the right-hand side of
the rule there should be a comparison
Franchi identity takes only one argument
so well so what do you say so it's an
order in reverse order or something
weird like that between returns
I understand but it's order is right we
don't have reverse order not that we
ordered or or that slash star not wait
we have ordered queue
yeah
so it's like this would be I mean it's
it's like reverse or it would be yeah
okay this is a hard
okay listen let's get something on the
agenda soon for sort by and this to
decide on how we deal with multiple
sorting criteria make sense yeah okay no
yeah I was thinking about the Teague
specification also you can take a list
and we haven't recovered that and I
think it's much easier to implement and
very useful so you wanna say is keep the
first two and give me the resulting six
and at the other question is whether we
should have an implicit up to here or
not I mean what happens if there are no
friends I don't think we should have an
implicit up to I think it should have
been error well the problem is that if
when this thing appears itself into an
entity function then it's almost
impossible like some will fail some want
it's really data dependent okay so I
have to wrap up here so you know we'll
need to continue this um okay I think
we've made good progress thanks
um okay see you all soon and who was the
the yeah you'll get you'll get this
notebook right I don't have to send this
to you right yes
thanks okay terrific okay thanks a lot
okay so yes